sequential models in karass
my name is richard kirschner with the
simply learn team that's www
www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead
what is in it for you today we're going
to cover what is keras
computational graphs
what are neural networks sequential
models and then we'll do a hands-on demo
so you can see what's going on with
sequential models and cross
so what is cross
cross is a high level python deep
learning api
which is used for easy implementation of
neural networks it has multiple
low-level back-ends like tensorflow
fano
pi torch etc which are used for fast
computation
so you can think of this as cross being
almost its own little programming
language
and then it sits on neural networks in
this case uh the ones listed were
tensorflow thano and pytorch which can
all integrate with the cross model
this makes it very diverse and also
makes it very easy to use and switch
around with different things
cross is very
user friendly as far as neural network
software goes as a high level api
computational graphs
so computational graphs are really the
heart and soul of neural networks
we talk about a computational graph
they are a visual representation of
expressing and evaluating mathematical
equations the nodes and data flow in a
graph correspond to mathematical
operations and variables
you'll hear a lot
some of the terms you might hear are
node and edge the edge being the data
flow in this case
it could also represent an actual value
they have
oh i think in spark they have a graph x
which works just on computing edges
there's all kinds of stuff that has
evolved from computational graphs we're
focusing just on keras and on neural
networks so we're not going to go into
great detail on everything a
computational graph does
it is a core component of a neural
network is what's important to know on
this
so cross offers a python user-friendly
front-end while maintaining a strong
computation power by using a low-level
api
like tensorflow pi torch etc which use
computational graphs as a back end
so one this allows for abstraction of
complex problems while specifying
control flow
if you've ever looked at some of the
backend or the original versions of
tensorflow
it's really a nightmare you have all
these different settings you have to put
in there and create it's a lot a lot of
back-end programming this is like the
old computers when you had to
tell it how to dispose of a variable and
how to properly re-allocate the memory
for use
all that is covered nowadays in our
higher level programming well this is
the same thing with cross is it covers a
lot of this stuff and does things for
you that you could spend hours on just
trying to figure out
it's useful for calculating derivatives
by using back propagation
we're definitely not going to teach a
class on derivatives
in this little video
but understanding
a derivative is the rate of change so if
you have a particular function you're
using in your neural network a lot of
them is just simple
y equals mx plus b
your euclidean geometry where you just
have a simple slope times the intercept
and they get very complicated they have
the inverse tangent function for
activation as opposed to just a linear
euclidean model and you can think about
this as you have your data coming in and
you have to alter it somehow
well you alter it going down to get an
answer you end up with an error and that
error goes back up and you have to have
that back propagation with the
derivative you want to know how it
changed so that you can figure out how
to adjust it for the error
a lot of that's hidden so you don't even
have to worry about it with cross and in
today's cross you'll even if you create
your own
formula for computing an answer it will
automatically compute the back prop the
the derivative for you in a lot of cases
it's easier to implement distributed
computation
so cross is really nice way to package
it and get it off on different computers
and share it and it allows parallelism
which means that two operations can run
simultaneously
so as we start developing these back
ends it can do all kinds of cool things
and utilize multiple cores gpus on a
computer
to get that parallel processing up
what are neural networks
well like i said there are already we've
talked about in computational edges you
have a node and you have a connection or
your edge so neural networks are
algorithms fashioned after the human
brain which contain multiple layers each
layer contains a node called a neuron
which performs a mathematical operation
they break down complex problems into
simple operations
so one an input layer takes in our data
and pre-processes it
when we talk about pre-processing when
you're dealing with neural networks you
usually have to pre-process your data so
that it's between
minus one and one or zero and one
into some kind of value that's usable
that occurs before it gets to the neural
network in fact eighty percent of data
science is usually in prepping that data
and getting it ready for your different
models
two you have hidden layer performs a
non-linear transformation of input
now it can do a hidden a linear
transformation it can use just a basic
euclidean geometry and you could think
of a node adding all the different
connections coming in
so each connection would have a weight
and then it would add to that weight
plus an intercept in the note itself so
you can actually use euclidean geometry
but a lot of these get really
complicated they have all these
different formulas and they're really
cool to look at but when you start
looking at them look at how they work
you really don't need to know the high
math behind it
to figure them out and figure out what
they're doing
which is really cool that means a lot of
people can use this without having to go
get a phd in mathematics
number three the output layer takes the
results from hidden layer transform them
and gives a final output
so sequential models
so what makes this a sequential model
sequential models are linear stacks of
layers where one layer leads to the next
it is simple and easy to implement and
you just have to make sure that the
previous layer is the input to the next
layer
so you have used for plain stack of
layers where each layer has one input
and one output tensor and this is what
tensorflow is named after is each one of
these layers is like a tensor each each
node is a tensor and then the layer is
also considered a tensor of values
and it's used for simple classifier
declassifier models you can it's also
used for regression models too so it's
not just about uh this is something this
is a teapot this is a cat this is a dog
it's also used for generating um uh
regret the actual values you know this
is worth ten dollars that's worth thirty
dollars the weather is going to be 90
degrees out or whatever it is so you can
use it for both classifier and
declassifier models
and one more note when we talk about
sequential models the term sequential is
used a lot and it's used in different
areas and different notations when
you're in data science so when we talk
about time series we'll talk about
sequential that is something very
different sequential in this case means
it goes from the input to layer 1 to
layer 2 to the output so it's very
directional
it's important to note this because if
you have a sequential model can you have
a non-sequential model and the answer is
yes
if you master the basics of a sequential
model you can just as easily have
another model that shares layers um you
can have another model where you have an
input coming in and it splits and then
you have one set that's doing one set of
nodes maybe they're doing a yes no kind
of node where it's either putting out a
zero or a one a classifier and the other
one might be regression it's just
processing numbers and then you
recombine them for the output
that's what they call across the cross
api
so there's a lot of different
availabilities in here and all kinds of
cool things you can do as far as
encoding and decoding and all kinds of
things and you can share layers and
things like that
we're just focusing on the basic cross
model with the sequential model
so let's dive into the meat of the
matter let's do and do a demo on here
today's demo in this demo we'll be
performing flower classification using
sequential model and cross and we'll use
our model to classify between five
different types of flowers
now for this demo and you can do this
demo on whatever platform you want or
whatever
user interface for developing python
i'm actually using anaconda and then i'm
using jupyter notebooks to develop in
and if you're not familiar with this you
can go under environment once you've
created environment you can come in here
to open a terminal window
and if you don't have the different
modules in here you can do your conda
install whatever module it is
just happened that this particular setup
didn't have a seaborn in it which i
already installed
so here's our anaconda and then i'm
going to go back
and start up my jupiter notebook
where i already created a
new uh python project python 3. i'm in
python 3.8 on this particular one
sequential model for flowers
so lots of fun there uh so we're going
to jump right into this the first thing
is to make sure you have all your
modules installed
so if you don't have numpy pandas
matplot library and seaborn in the cross
an sklearn or a site kit it's not
actually sklearn you'll need to go ahead
and install all of those
now having done this for years and
having switched environments and doing
different things
i get all my imports done and then we
just run it and if we get an error we
know we have to go back and install
something
um
right off the bat though we have numpy
pandas matplot library seaborn these are
built on top of each other panda's the
data frame and built on top of numpy the
data array
and then we bring in our sklearn or
scikit this is the scikit setup sci
kit
even though you use sk learn to bring it
in it's a scikit and then our cross we
have our pre-processing the images image
data generator
our model this is our basic model our
sequential model
and then we bring in from cross layers
import dents
optimizers
these optimizers a lot of them already
come in these are your different
optimizers and it's almost a lot of this
is so automatic now
adam
is the a lot of times the default
because you're dealing with a large data
and then we get our sgd which is smaller
data does better on smaller pieces of
data
and i'm not going to go into all of
these
different optimizers we didn't even use
these in the actual demo you just have
to be aware that they are different
optimizers and the digger the more you
dig into these models
you'll hit a point where you do need to
play with these a little bit but for the
most part leave it at the default when
you're first starting out
and we're doing just the sequential
you'll see here layers dense
and then if we come down a little bit
more when they put this together and
they're running the dense layers you'll
also see they have dropout they have
flattened they have activation
they have the convolutional
layer 2d max pooling 2d
batch normalization
what are all these layers and when we
get to the model we're going to talk
about them a lot of times when you're
just starting you can just import cross
dot layers and then you have your
dropout your flattened
your convolutional
neural network 2d
and we'll we'll cover what these do
in the actual example when we get down
there what i want you to take from here
though is you need to run your imports
and load your different aspects of this
and of course your tensorflow tf because
this is all built on tensorflow
and then finally import random is rn
just for random generation
and then we get down here we have our
cv2
that is your
open image or your opencv they call it
for processing images that's what the
cvd 2 is
we have our tqdm
the tqdm is for
is a progress bar just a fancy way of
adding when you're running a process you
can view the bar going across in the
jupiter
setup not really necessary but it's kind
of fun to have
we want to be able to shuffle some files
again these are all different things
pill is another
image processor it goes with the cv2 a
lot of times you'll see both of those
and so we run those we've got to bring
them all in
and the next thing is to set up our
directories
and so we come into the directories
there's an important thing to note on
here other than we're looking at a lot
of flowers which is fun
as we get down here we have our
directory archive flowers that just
happens to be where the different
files for different flowers are put in
we're denoting an x and a z
and the x is the date of the image and
the z is the tag for it what kind of
flower is this
and the image size is really important
because we have to resize everything if
you have a neural network and if you
remember from our neural networks let me
flip back to that slide
we look at this light we have two input
nodes here with an image you have an
input node
depending on how you set it up for each
pixel and that pixel has three different
color schemes usually in it sometimes
four so if you have a picture that's 150
by 150
you multiply 150 times 150 times three
that's how many nodes input layer is
coming in i mean so this is a massive
input a lot of times you think oh yeah
it's just a small amount of data or
something like that
no it's a full image coming in
and then you have your hidden layers a
lot of times they match what the image
size is coming in so each one of those
is also just as big and then we get down
to just a single output
so that's kind of a thing to note in
here what's going on behind the scenes
and of course each one of these layers
has a lot of processes and stuff going
on
and then we have our different
directories on here let me go and run
that so i'm just setting the directories
that's all this is
archive flowers daisy sunflower tulip
dandelion rose
just our different directories that
we're going to be looking at
uh and then we want to go ahead and we
need to assign labels remember we
defined x and z
so we're just going to create a
definition here
and the first thing is a return flower
type okay
it just returns it what kind of flower
it is i guess a sign label to it
but we're going to go ahead and make our
train data
and when you look at this there's a
couple things to take away from here uh
the first one is we're just appending
right onto our numpy array the image
we're gonna let numpy handle all that
different
aspects as far as 150 by 150 by three
we just dump it right into the numpy
which makes it really easy we don't have
to do anything funky on the processing
and we want to leave it like that and
i'm going to talk about that in a minute
and then of course we have to have the
string append the label on there and i
want you to notice right here uh we're
going to read the image in
and then we're going to size it and this
is important because we're just changing
this to 150 by 150 we're resizing the
image so it's uniform every image comes
in identical to the other ones uh this
is something that's so important is um
when you're resizing or reformatting
your data you really have to be aware of
what's going on
with images it's not a big deal because
with an image you just resize it so it
looks squishy or spread out or stretched
the neural network picks up on that and
it doesn't really change how it
processes it
so let's go ahead and run that
and now we've got our definition set up
on there
and then we want to go ahead and make
our
training data
so make the train data
daisy flower daisy directory
print length of x so here we go let's go
and run that
and we're just loading up the flower
daisy so this is going all in there and
it's setting
it's adding it in to the our setup on
there to our x and z setup
and we see we have 769
um and then of course you can see this
nice bar here this is the bar going
across is that little added
code in there that just makes it really
cool for doing demos
not necessarily when you're building
your own model or something like that
but if you're going to display this to
other people
adding that little what was it called
tqdm i can never remember that but the
tqdm module in there is really nice and
we'll go ahead and do sunflowers and of
course you could have just
created an array of these
but this has an interesting problem
that's going to come up and i want to
show you something it doesn't matter how
good the people in the back are or how
good you are programming
errors are going to come up and you got
to figure out how to handle them
and so when we get all the way down to
the
[Music]
where is it dandelion here's our
dandelion directory we're going to build
jupiter has some cool things it does
which makes this really easy to deal
with
but at the same time you want to go back
in there depending on how many times you
rerun this how many times you pull this
so when you're finding errors
going in here there's a couple things
you can do and we're just going to oh it
wasn't there it is there's our error i
knew there was an error
this processed
1062 out of 1065.
now i can do a couple things one i could
go back into our definition
and i can just put in here try and so if
it has a bad conversion this is where
the error is coming from
just skip it that's one way to do it
when you're doing a lot of work in data
science and you look at something like
this where you're losing three points of
data at the end you just say okay i lost
three points who cares
or you can go in there and try to delete
it
it really doesn't matter for this
particular demo
and so we're just going to leave that
error right alone and skip over because
it's already added all the other files
in there and this is wonderful thing
about jupiter notebook
is that i can just continue on there and
the x and z which we're creating
is still
running and we'll just go right into the
next flower rose so all these flowers
are in there
that's just a cool thing about jupiter
notebook
uh and then we can go ahead and just
take a quick look
and see
what we're dealing with and this is of
course really when you're dealing with
the other people and showing them stuff
this is just kind of fun where we can
display it on the plot library here
and we're just going to go through and
see what we got here
uh looks like
we're gonna do like five of each of them
i think
is that how they set this up um
plot library five by two okay oh i see
how they did it okay so two each so we
have five by two set up on our axes and
we're just going to go in and look at a
couple of these flowers
it's always a good thing to look at some
of your data
no matter what you're doing
we've reformatted this to 150 by 150
you can see how it really blurs this one
up here on the tulip
that is that resize to 150 by 150
and these are what's actually going in
these are all 150 by 150 images you can
check the dimensions on the side
and you can see just a quick sampling of
the flowers we're actually going to
process on here
and again like i said at the beginning
most of your work in data science is
reprocessing
this different information so we need to
go ahead and take our labels
and run a label encoder on there and
then we're just going to le is a label
encoder one of the things we imported
and then we always use the fit
to categorical y comma 5 x here's our
array
x so if you look at this here's our fit
we're going to transform z
that's our z array we created
and then we have y which equals that and
then we go ahead and do to categorical
we want five different categories
and then we create our x
in p array of x x equals x over 255.
so what's going on here there's two
different transformations one we've
turned our categories into
0 1 2 3 4 5 as the output
and we have taken our x array
and remember the x array is three values
of your different colors
this is so important to understand when
we do this across a numpy array this
takes every one of those three colors so
we have 150 by 150 pixels
out of those 150 by 150 pixels they each
have three
color arrays and those color arrays
range from 0 to 250. so when we take the
x equals x over 255
i'm sorry range from 0 to 255.
this converts all those pixels to a
number between 0 and 1.
and you really want to do that when
you're working with neural networks
now if you do a linear regression model
it doesn't affect it as much and so you
don't have to do that conversion if
you're doing straight numbers but when
you're running neural networks if you
don't do this you're going to create a
huge bias
and that means it'll do really good on
predicting one or two things and they'll
just totally die on a lot of other
predictions
so now we have our
x and y values
x being the data n y being our known
output
and with any good setup we want to
divide this data into our training
so we have x train
we have our x test this is the data
we're not going to program the model
with
and of course your y train corresponds
to your x train and your y test
corresponds to your x test the outputs
and this is uh when we do the train test
split this was from the site kit sklearn
we imported train test split and we're
just going to go ahead and do the test
size at about a quarter of the data 0.25
and of course random is always good
this is such a good tool i mean
certainly you can do your own division
um
you know you could just take the first
you know 0.25 of the data or whatever do
the length of the data not real hard to
do
but this is randomized so if you're
running this test a few times you can
kind of get an idea whether it's going
to work or not
sometimes what i will do
is i'll just split the data into three
parts
and then i'll test it on two with one
being the uh or i train it on two of
those parts with one being the test and
i rotate it so i come up with three
different answers which is a good way of
finding out just how good your model is
but for setting up let's stick with the
x train x test and the sk learn package
and then we're going to go ahead and do
a random seed
now a lot of times the cross actually
does this automatically but we're going
to go ahead and set it up on here and
you can see we did an np random seed
from 42 and we get a nice rn number
and then we do tf random we set the seed
so you can set your randomness at the
beginning of your tensorflow and that's
what the
tf.random.set is
so that's a lot of prep
all this prep and then we finally get to
the exciting part
this is where you probably spend once
you have the data prepped and you have
your pipeline going
and you have everything set up on there
this is the part that's exciting is
building these models
and so we look at this model one we're
going to designate a sequential
they have the api which is across the
cross tensorflow api versus sequential
sequential means we're going one layer
to the next so we're not going to split
the layer and bring it back together
it looks almost the same with the
exception of
bringing it back together so it's not a
huge step to go from this to an api
and the first thing we're going to look
at is um our convolutional neural
network in 2d
so what's going on here there's a lot of
stuff that's going on here
um the default for well let's start with
the beginning what is a convolutional 2d
network
well convolutional 2d network creates a
number of small windows and those small
windows float over the picture
and each one of them is their own neural
network and it's
basically um becomes like a uh um
a categorization and then it looks at
that and it says oh if we add these
numbers up a certain way
uh we can find out whether this is the
right flower based on this this little
window floating around which looks at
different things
and we have filters 32 so this is
actually creating 32 windows is what
that's doing
and the kernel size is 5x5 so we're
looking at a 5x5 square
remember it's 150 by 150 so this narrows
it down to a five by five it's a two d
so it has your x y coordinates
and we look at this five by five
remember each one of these is is
actually looking at five by five by
three
so we're actually looking at 15 by 15
different
pixels
and padding is just
usually just ignore that
activation by default is relu we went
ahead and put the relu in there
there's a lot of different activations
relu is for your smaller uh
when you remember i mentioned atom when
you have a lot of datum data use an atom
kind of activation or using atom
processing
we're using the relu here
it kind of gives you a yes or no but it
it doesn't give you a full yes or no it
has a
zero and then it kind of shoots off at
an angle very common it's the most
common one and then of course here's our
input shape 150 by 150 by 3 pixels
and then we have to pull it so whenever
you have a two convolutional 2d
layer
we have to bring this back together and
pull this into a neural network and then
we're going to go ahead and repeat this
so we're going to add another network
here
one of the cool things if you look at
this is that it as it comes in it just
kind of automatically assumes you're
going down to the next layer
and so we have another convolutional
null network 2d
here's our max pooling again we're going
to do that again max pooling
and we're just going to filter on down
now one of the things they did on this
one is they changed the kernel size they
changed the number of filters and so
each one of these steps
kind of looks at the data a little bit
differently
and that's kind of cool because then you
get a little added filtering on there
this is where you start playing with the
model you might be looking at a
convolutional neural network which is
great for image classifications
when we get down to here one of the
things we see is flattened so we add we
just flatten it remember this is 150 by
150 by 3.
well and actually
the pool size changes so it's actually
smaller than that flattened just puts
that into a 1d array so instead of being
you know a tensor of this really
complexity with the the pixels and
everything it's just flat
and then the dense
is just another activation on there
by default it is probably relu as far as
its activation
and then oh yeah here we go in
sequential they actually added the
activation as relu so this just because
this is sequential this activation is
attached to the dents
and there's a lot of different
activations but relu is the most common
one and then we also see a soft max
softmax
is similar
but it has its own kind of variation
and one of the cool things you know what
let me bring this up because if we if
you don't know about these activations
this doesn't make sense
and i just did a quick google search on
images of tensorflow activations
um i should probably look at which set
website this is
but this is the output of the values uh
so as your x as it adds in all those uh
weighted x values going into the node
it's going to activate it a certain way
and that's a sigmoid activation and you
can see it goes between 0 and 1 and has
a nice curve there this also shows the
derivatives
and if we come down the seven popular
activation functions non-linear
activations there's a lot of different
options on this let me see if i can find
the
oops let me swing find the specific
terelu
so this is a leaky rayloo
and you can see instead of it just being
zero and then a value between uh going
up it has a little leaky there otherwise
your relu loses some nodes they just
become inactive
but you can see there's a lot of
different options here here's a good one
right here with the rayleigh you can see
the rayleigh function on the upper on
the upper left here and then the leaky
rayleigh over here on the right which is
very commonly used also
one of the things i use with processing
language is the sig as the exponential
one
or the tangent h the hyperbolic tangent
because they have that nice funky curve
that comes in that has a whole different
meaning and captures word use better
again these are very specific to domain
and you can spend a lot of time
playing with different models
for our basic model we'll stick to the
relu and the softmax on here and we'll
go ahead and run and build this model
so now that we've had fun playing with
all these different models that we can
add in there
we need to go ahead and have a batch
size on here
128
epix10
this means that we're going to send 128
rows of data or flowers at a time to be
processed
and the epics 10 that's how many times
we're going to loop through all the data
and then there's all kinds of stuff you
can do again this is now built into a
lot of cross models already by default
so there's different ways to reduce
the values and
verbose verbose equals one means that
we're going to show what's going on
value the monitor what we're monitoring
we'll see that as we actually train the
model this is what's what's going to
come out of there if you set the verbose
equal to 0
you don't have to watch it train the
model although
it is kind of nice to actually know
what's going on
and sometimes we're still working on
bringing the data in here's our batch
side here's our epics we need to go
ahead and create a data generator
this is our image data generator
and it has all the different settings in
here almost all of these are defaults so
if you're looking at this going oh my
gosh this is confusing
most the time you can actually just
ignore most of this
vertical flip so you can randomly flip
pictures you can randomly horizontally
flick them
you can shift the picture around this
kind of helps gives you multiple data
off of them
zooming rotation there's all kinds of
different things you can do with images
most of these we're just going to leave
as false we don't really need to do all
that um setup because we already have a
huge amount of data
if you're short data you can start
flipping like a horizontal picture and
it will generate it's like doubling your
data almost
so the upside is you double your data
the downside is that if you already have
a bias in your data you already have
[Music]
5 000 sunflowers and only two roses
that's a huge bias it's also going to
double that bias
that is the downside of that
and so we have our model compile and
this you're going to see in all the
cross we're going to take this model
here
we're going to take all this information
as far as how we want it to go and we're
going to compile it
this actually builds the model and so
we're going to run that and i want you
to notice uh
learning rate
very important this is the default zero
zero one
um there's there you really don't this
is how
slowly it adjusts to find the right
answer
and the more data you have you might
actually make this a smaller number um
with larger with you have a very small
sample of data you might go even larger
than that
and then we're going to look at the loss
categorically categorical cross entropy
most commonly used
and this is uh how how much it improves
the model is improving is what this
number means or yeah that's that's
important on there and then the accuracy
we want to know just how good our model
is on the accuracy
and then
one of the cool things to do is if
you're in a group of people who are
studying the model if you're in
shareholders you don't want to do this
as you can run the model summary
i do this by default and you can see the
different layers that you built into
this model just a quick summary on there
so we went ahead and we're going to go
ahead and create a
we'll call it history but we want to do
a model fit generator
and so what this history is doing is
this is tracking what's going on as
while it fits
the model
now there's a lot of new setups in here
where they just use fit and then you put
the generator in here
we're going to leave it like this even
though the new default
is a little different on that it doesn't
really matter it does the same thing and
we'll go ahead and just run that
and you can see while it's running right
here uh we're going through the epics we
have one of ten now we're going through
six to 25.
here's our loss we're printing that out
so you can see how it's improving and
our accuracy the accuracy gets better
and better and this is 6 out of 25. this
is going to take a couple minutes to
process
because we are training 150 by 150 by
three pixels across uh six layers or
eight layers whatever it was
that is a huge amount of processing so
this will take a few minutes to process
this is when we talk about the hardware
and the problems that come up in data
science and why it's only now just
exploding being able to do neural
networks this is why this process takes
a long time
now you should have seen a jump on the
screen here because i did
pause the recorder to let this go ahead
and run all the way through its epics
let's go ahead and take a look and see
what these epics are and if you set the
verbose to
zero instead of one it won't show what's
going on in the behind the scenes as
it's training it so we look at this epic
10 epic so we went through all the data
10 times
if i remember correctly there's roughly
a gig of data there so that's a lot of
data
the first thing you're going to notice
is the
270 seconds
that's how much each of those epics took
to run
and so if you divide 60 in there you
roughly get about five minutes worth of
each epic so if i have 10 epics that's
50 minutes almost an hour of run time
that's a big deal we talk about
processing uh in on this particular
computer
i actually have what is it
eight cores with 16 dedicated threads so
it runs like a 16 core computer it
alternates the threads going in
and it still takes it five minutes for
each one of these epics so you start to
see that if you have a lot of data
this is going to be a problem if you
have a number of models you want to find
out how good the models are doing and
what model to use
and so each of those models could take
all night to run in fact i have a model
i'm running now that takes over
takes about a day and a half to test
each model
it takes four days to do with the whole
data
so what i do is i actually take a small
piece of the data
test it out to find out uh get an idea
of how the different setups are gonna do
and then i increase that size of the
data and then increase it again and i
can just take that that curve and kind
of say okay if the data is doing this
then i need to add in more dense layers
or whatever
so you can do a small chunks of data and
then figure out what it costs to do a
large set of data and what kind of model
you want
the loss as we see here continues to go
down
this is the error this is how much error
is in there it really isn't a
user friendly number other than
the more it trends down the better and
so if you continue to see the loss going
down eventually get to the point where
it stops going down and it goes up and
down and kind of wavers a little bit at
that point you know you've run too many
epics you're starting to get a bias in
there and it's not going to give you
a good model fit
the accuracy just turns us into
something that
we can use
and so the accuracy is what percentage
of guesses in this case is categorical
so this is the percentage of guesses are
correct
value loss is similar you know it's a
minus a value loss
and then you have the value accuracy and
you'll see the value accuracy is pretty
similar to the accuracy um just rounds
it off basically and so a lot of times
you come down here and you go okay we're
doing point five point six
point seven and that is seventy percent
accuracy or in this case sixty eight
point uh
five nine percent accuracy that's a very
usable number and it's very important to
have if you're identifying flowers
that's probably good enough if you can
get within a close distance and knowing
what flower you're identifying
if you're trying to figure out whether
someone's going to die from a heart
attack or not you might want to rethink
it a little bit or re-key how you're
building your model
so
if i'm working with a
a group of
clients
shareholders in a company or something
like that
you don't really want to show them this
you don't want to show them hey you know
this is what's going on with the
accuracy these are just numbers and so
we want to go and put the finishing
touches just like when you are building
a house and you put in the frame and the
trim on the house it's nice to have
something a nice view of what's going on
and so we'll go ahead and do a
pie plot and we'll just plot the history
of the loss
the history of the
value loss
over here
epics train and test and so we're just
going to compute these
this is really important and what i want
you to notice right here is when we get
to about oh
five epics a little more than five six
epics you see a cross over here
and it starts crossing as far as the
value loss and what's going on here is
you have the loss in your actual model
and your actual data and you have the
value loss where it's testing it against
the the test data the data wasn't used
to program your model it wasn't used to
train your model on
and so when we see this crossing over
this is where the bias is coming in this
is becoming over fitted and so when you
put these two together
right around five and six you start to
see how it does this this switch over
here and that's really where you need to
stop right around five yeah six
um
it's always hard to guess because at
this point the model is kind of a black
box see but you know that right around
here if you're saving your model after
each run you want to use the one that's
right around five epics because that's
the one that's going to have the least
amount of bias so this is really
important as far as guessing what's
going on with your model and its
accuracy and when to stop
it also is you know i don't show people
this mess up here
i show somebody this kind of model and i
say this is where the training and the
testing comes in on this model
it just makes it easier to see and
people can understand what's going on
so that completes our demo and you can
see we did what we were set out to do we
took our flowers and we were able to
classify them within about 68 70
accuracy whether it's going to be a
dahlia sunflower cherry blossom rose
a lot of other things you can do with
your output as far as a
different tables to see
where the errors are coming from and
what problems are coming up
so
thank you for joining us today with
simply learn for more information please
visit www.simplylearn.com
get certified get ahead
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here